[Musique]
françois michel lambert bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france alors vous allez
réagir avec nous sur l'actualité mal
très mal marqué ces dernières heures par
la visite de deux jours du chef de
l'état dans le lot
en marge de cette visite emmanuel macron
qui a annoncé la vaccination ouverte
pour les 12 18 ans le 15 juin est ce que
c'est une bonne chose selon vous la
bonne chose c'est qu'enfin nous sommes à
la hauteur des enjeux en termes de
vaccination je rappelle que dès le mois
de janvier
j'avais prenez une stratégie d'ampleur
qui n'a démarré malheureusement que fin
mars début avril
alors que nous avions la possibilité la
stratégie du gouvernement de se
concentrer sur certaines populations et
ne pas utiliser toutes les 12 et bien
aura des conséquences puisque certaines
personnes auraient pu recevoir des
vaccins plus tôt et on sait très bien
que plus vite les populations la
population dans son ensemble est
vaccinée plus vite nous sortons de cette
situation dans laquelle nous sommes face
au co vie de dix neuf donc
il était temps et aujourd'hui je me
satisfais de la vitesse de croisière que
nous avons prises mais comme dans la
fable du lièvre et de la tortue
la france a joué au lièvre attendre
attendre qu'à cause très vite à la fin
mais elle restera toujours en retard car
l'air démarré très en retard alors le
chef de l'état qui est aussi abordé la
question du masque pour le moment il
reste en vigueur mais sont pour à
l'extérieur sera évaluée en fonction des
territoires et quelques heures plus tôt
le préfet des bouches du rhône à là où
vous êtes a lui décidé de lever le port
du masque à l'extérieur qu'est ce que
vous en pensez c'est au lait aux élus
locaux aujourd'hui de décider dès
maintenant s'ils port du masque aux doit
être levé en extérieur ou pas selon la
situation
mais permettez moi de parler de
l'expérience allemande en allemagne
vous devez avoir un masque ffp2 de bien
meilleures performances pour la
filtration d'ailleurs de confort bien
meilleurs dans chaque fois que vous
rentrez dans un espace clos ou lorsqu'il
ya un gros attroupement
mais dans le reste du temps vous êtes en
liberté de ne porter ou ne pas porter le
masque dans la rue donc je pense que
nous ferions mieux de nous inspirer des
stratégies mises en oeuvre notamment en
allemagne
aller vers des masques plus performants
les ffp2 et par là-même libérer les
espaces grands ouverts comme évidemment
les plages mais aussi la rue lorsqu'il
ya dix personnes dans une rue porter un
masque parfois semble plus une
contrainte que une protection justifié
donc je crois que nous protégeons pas là
où nous devrions protéger je le redis
des masques ffp2 dans les espaces clos
les commerces dans l'est dans les lieux
où on se regroupe et plus de liberté au
grand air alors en tout cas les vacances
c'est en france cette année a prévenu le
chef de l'état une injection qui n'est
pas forcément passé notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux quand on regarde on peut
le constater comment vous vous l'avez
reçu vous ce message du président je
suis d'accord avec le président de la
république
la france elle est belle d'ailleurs j'ai
relu le livre de pierre contre gm et à
chacun lire la belle france et d'autres
livres de carbone qui décrit très bien
cette france qu'on voulait on a oublié
que l'on doit retrouver
c'est aussi une façon de réparer de
façon générale la france mais aussi ses
territoires beaucoup plus ruraux ces
territoires qui ont été abandonnés par
les services publics notamment par la
start up nation par la pensée de macron
qui ne pensait que centre ville de paris
qui avait complètement biais que la
france c'était cette diversité comme
disait le général de gaulle c'est france
aux 250 fromage aujourd'hui on est une
île fromage
cette belle france elle n'est elle
mérite elle doit être
deux lieux de destination de vacances
privilégier d'abord or éviter les
déplacements certes mais surtout pour
que l'on re découvre notre force c'est
notre force c'est ce pays unique le
willy brandt disait la france ce n'est
pas un pays c'est un continent du fait
de toutes ces diversités et nous devons
savoir être au plus près dans ce qu'est
la vérité de la france où je devrais
dire les vérités les différences j'ai la
parcourt un petit peu et je découvre que
c'est à chaque fois un pays différent
donc oui les vacances c'est en france le
chef de l'état donc qui a tenu ces
propos en marge de sa rencontre avec les
français il était dans le village
touristique de saint cirq lapopie
pour citer pour je vais le site et
prendre le pouls est des français alors
dans cette commune 70 % avaient voté
pour lui on peut le rappeler comment est
ce que vous percevez plus généralement
cette démarche ce tour de france
le président qui veut prendre son bâton
de pèlerin pour aller à la rencontre des
français
prendre le pouls des français en l1 à
saint cirq lapopie qu est très très joli
et que je connais c'est quand même
fabuleux qui fusent et vous avez vu les
images avec une armada de journalistes
je suis pas sûr que il est bien pris le
coup il devrait d'histoire le chaque
pays est empli de sécher ou un un
monarque eux parce que monet macro et
quelque part un peu un monarque se
déguisant paysans et parcours pour mieux
découvrir son pays dans l'anonymat
si vous êtes ça ou qu'il s'entoure n'ont
pas de personnes tel qu'il a aujourd'hui
autour de lui qui sont complètement
déconnectés de notre pays qui sont
parisiano parisien mais quand même très
très rattaché à une communauté un espace
assez fermé et qu' il puisse avoir un
dialogue avec ceux qui
pour on lui dira même s'il reste à
l'elysée ce qui est cette belle france
donc je ne crois pas qu'un tour de
france comme peut-être là le tour de
france à vélo où on voit les caravanes
qui déroule qui déboule comment pensez
vous qu'elles soient au contact avec la
population avec le quotidien avec les
difficultés avec les matinées qui sont
pas faciles avec les difficultés de
déplacement avec les soirées qui eux
peuvent être loin des espaces de
culturel avec les angoisses des services
publics
c'est pas en allant à saint-cirq-lapopie
qui très joli et j'invite chacun à les
découvrir
mais ce n'est pas là qu'est tout rire à
toutes ces difficultés toutes ses
particularités et notamment dé france où
il n'ya pas de tourisme et ça c'est
celle que l'on risque de vraiment oublié
est bien loin de saint cirq lapopie
qu'ils aillent est une ville extrêmement
touristique commune extrêmement
touristique alors une région du lot qui
représenta pour le chef de l'état l'a
encore je vais citer ses mots l'exemple
d'une ruralité heureuse et pourtant on
va le voir un tout de suite sur sur des
images ses habitants de la région qui se
sont rassemblés pour protester on le
voit contre la politique du gouvernement
c'est hier en marge de la visite alors
une réalité pas si heureuse que cela
selon vous
ça mais elle souhaite deux choses
d'abord on sent la starter nation et
c'est pas avec celui qui a promu la
start up nation c'est pas et kaman et le
maquereau et tout son staff de deux mecs
autour de lui qui est très loin de ces
réalités locales
e on saura en reconnaissance de cette
rivalité heureuse et puis la seconde
c'est apporter ce qui est des faits
depuis la les mêmes niveaux de
reconnaissance de protection une commune
à ces territoires
et force est de constater que depuis
2010 est c'est plutôt l'inversé que nous
connaissons est d'ailleurs la loi à
venir qui en débat au sénat ce mois ci
la loi dite chaldée ou décentralisation
déconcentration différenciation et des
complexification vous voyez déjà que les
technocrates parisiens ont eu un délire
dans leur dénomination de cette cette
loi mais bon passons
et bien cette loi 4d c'est avant tout
une loi qui va encore contraindre les
territoires les plus fragiles les plus
éloignés du centre ville de paris et ça
ce n'est pas acceptable donc moi je
pense que la ruralité heureuse c'est
d'abord celle que nous faisons en termes
de politiques publiques et c'est pas
celle qui est menée actuellement bientôt
vient de construire alors en tout cas
certains observateurs ou alors également
dans l'opposition dénoncent une campagne
présidentielle le début d'une campagne
présidentielle finalement masqué est ce
que c'est ce que vous observez aussi au
jeu je vais pas critiquer je pense que
tout élu à l'échéance de sa réélection
fait le même type de deux tours de
pardon de circonscription de sa commune
de sa région et en l'occurrence de la
france pour le président la république
ce que je souhaite c'est que ce ne soit
pas artificiel or c'est extrêmement
artificiers on est très loin de la
réalité vous avez les images de très
loin de la réalité de ce que nous
pourrions espérer ou de ce qu'il faut
comprendre et connaître pour ma part moi
je suis très attaché un département
rural
suivez candy est le plus rural de france
le gers où un tiers des professions sont
autour de l'activité agricole
eh bien je me vois mal je vois mal le
président de la république comprendre au
quotidien on a là où bat au café ou au
tabac en allant chez le boulanger chez
le boucher rencontré l'agriculteur ou
tout simplement se balader sur les
chemins de saint jacques de compostelle
et comprendre ce qui est heureux dans
cette ruralité
mais où sont les difficultés je pense
que c'est pas parce tour de france qu'il
comprendra ceci mais plutôt par la
capacité à avoir des personnes qui lui
disent ou à faire le choix d'un anonymat
je ne sais comment il peut le faire cet
anonymat pour découvrir pleinement la
réalité de notre france et ne vont pas
dans ce tour de france très artificielle
comme fait la une de libé remettant
cochonou en avant avec macron sur la
deux chevaux de cochonou hisser sa il
passe en vitesse et il dit qu'il connaît
la france dont il ne connaît pas la
france
alors un an des élections
présidentielles dans ce contexte
électoral le gouvernement par la voix du
député européen stéphane ces journées
est bien se dit favorable au décompte
des temps de parole des éditorialistes
des chaînes infos notamment regarder on
voit depuis quelques années sur les
chaînes info une grille des programmes
remplacé par la priorité au direct et
une sur éditorialisation les programmes
progressivement les éditorialistes ont
remplacé les responsables politiques
on vous en pensez quoi de ce décompte
demandé par stéphane ces journées pour
les éditorialistes sur les chaînes info
c'est le fantasme de la république en
marche on avait déjà eu six bêtes
n'diaye qui voulait mettre en place et
structure de contrôle de la publication
journalistique
donc voilà on marche n'est pas forcément
la république en marche n'est pas
forcément une république qui acceptent
la séparation des pouvoirs
nous l'avons vu à elle que gérald
darmanin qui en tant que ministre
participe à une manifestation de
policiers contre la justice
nous le voyons avec une nouvelle attaque
contre les médias moi je suis
extrêmement critique de des médias mais
je leur dis en face à face mais je ne
leur met pas de bâtons dans les roues
je les laisse dans une liberté
c'est ce que nous devons chérir nous le
disons si souvent chérir la liberté
c'est aussi chercheur la liberté des
médias et faire confiance aux français
pour savoir prendre la distance
peut-être avec des éditorialistes et
confèrent plus confiance à leur
quotidien comprendre ce qu'ils vivent et
où ils trouveront des réponses en tout
cas c'est pas dans la start up nation
qui est pas dans la restriction des
libertés jamais nous avons eu autant de
restrictions de liberté depuis 50 ans en
france il faut le rappeler
sous mac rond c'est ça et on n'a pas
fini d'avoir des libertés qui s'amenuise
ne lâchant pas notre liberté ne lâchant
pas la liberté des médias
laissons les éditorialistes peut-être
être très politique et sachant se
retrouver dans nos propres valeurs
individuellement et voter en fonction et
notamment voté pour la belle france
papou la fosse pour la vraie star mme
sartre up nation que représente macron
et ses équipes merci beaucoup françois
michel lambert à d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france je le rappelle vous êtes député
liberté territoire des bouches du rhône